the way Wan Division will use the
multiverse to bring in Quicksilver Evan
Peters from the Fox Marvel Universe
they're gonna do the same to bring
Charlie Cox daredevil from the Netflix
Marvel world to a daredevil
Hawkeye crossover episode she will end
up meeting our friend daredevil
[Music]
stars this is rogue theory and I am
off-screen producer Zack
Huddleston they gave me the keys to the
castle and I'm gonna wreck it I believe
in you look Philip and Eric are really
gonna regret this speaking of home with
me to go rogue today to pitch their wild
fun theories about all the nerdy topics
we love we of course have the man the
myth the legend
Erik Voss hello we have a returning
guest a star of twitch and a wonderful
human Angelica Trey I'm trying to win
I'm trying to win everybody over with
positivity okay it's not hello youtuber
under a master tainment on youtube and
twitter our friend mt hey everybody
you guys made a big mistake dude very
strange man which is why you're gonna
fit in so well on this show it's we're
so stoked to have you empty and a gentle
go good to see you again but this is
empties first time on new rock stars so
just want to give them a bit of love
because this guy we've been like seen
your videos for years you've been doing
some amazing guardians of the galaxy
theories you've actually found [ __ ] that
James Gunn is like empties on it just
pick up the torch of empty this guy
knows what where I've hidden it so we're
so glad to finally have you on the show
dude I'm so glad to be here like
everyone's like dude empty like new rock
stars is like shouting you out and like
dude like who's the new rock shows I
checked out your stuff amazing [ __ ] oh
like you guys are doing God's work so
super appreciative to be on here let's
hope he's a forgiving nerd God not a
vengeance
speaking of forgiving so our arbors
topic today the the save daredevil
campaign has picked up some steam
recently obviously there's been a vocal
contingent of fans ever since the
Netflix series ended
who have been lobbying petitioning to
get the series brought back they
actually the save dear devil petition as
over 350 thousand signatures online
which is nuts but they they made
headlines this week because it is six
months from now kind of the sidon six
months to the expiration of the Netflix
rights deal over daredevil and those
riots reverting back to Marvel so in
theory Marvel could do something with
daredevil in the not-too-distant future
so that inspired us to make the first
question for today's road theory how
daredevil gonna show up in the MCU
pitch me the the plot the connection the
push credit scene however you think he's
going to show up and will this be
connected to the Charlie Cox Netflix
series or are we starting fresh with our
man with no fear Erik Bosse what do you
think oh okay um I think we gotta keep
Charlie Cox in this this guy's done so
much to identify this character his take
on daredevil has been fantastic on
Netflix and I think Disney Plus has a
way to work in that version of daredevil
into the MCU with wan division so I'm
sure you guys saw this news recently
that like Evan Peters who played
Quicksilver in the Fox Marvel side of
the universe is rumored to be on wan
division which would be crazy if true
and if he was playing Quicksilver
because that would mean want a vision a
show about the multiverse is gonna use
that multiverse logic whatever it is to
tie-in versions of Marvel heroes from
other franchises which they could do
with daredevil as well I think the way
Wan Division will use the multiverse to
bring in Quicksilver Evan Peters from
the Fox Marvel Universe they're gonna do
the same to bring Charlie Cox daredevil
from the Netflix Marvel world now I know
a lot of you are gonna be like well
that's already kind of in the MCU I
don't necessarily agree I think the MCU
in my mind is only the films that have
Kevin Feige PG a credited on them and I
think that precludes agents of shield
and agent Carter even as well like the
Marvel TV things like he hasn't had
direct oversight on all those things
that's why we have all these confusing
plot holes and disconnections despite
all the Netflix Marvel shows referencing
the Battle of New York
don't really reference the blip they
which I know a lot of them happened
before that they don't reference
sokovia as much they don't really
reference the Triskelion disaster
there's all kinds of other stuff that
happened wan division seems like it's
gonna toggle around a bunch of sitcom
realities right so we'll have a
bewitched episode a Brady Bunch episode
I think all that footage is from episode
1 of the series and that's just gonna be
episode 1 in a later episode maybe even
the finale we're gonna see a different
way that she's gonna go across mediums
maybe instead of like switching the
channel she's going to go into the pages
of comic books right like maybe she's
like trapped in this state of chaos and
vision like his ghostly presences in her
mind
trying to stabilize her and he's like
use the TV use the TV to try to find
these earthly reference points that
doesn't work so then maybe like in one
of those TV realities she does have kids
and those kids have comic books he's
like alright fine go into the pages of
these comics so within the episode we're
gonna be turning pages to different
superhero universes universe I know it's
a yes you don't need the us so I and I
think a lot of these other superhero
characters from other franchises that
Disney now has connections to they might
just be quick cameos or maybe we're just
alluding to certain things from their
worlds so maybe like a Daily Bugle
newspaper or maybe we might get a cameo
from JK Simmons since James jonah
Jameson maybe we'll see like the water
tower from Hell's Kitchen or fog Welles
gym or Josie's bar and that will tie in
we have a quick cameo from Charlie Cox
just like saying I'm now being dragged
into the MCU throughout this chaos like
Scarlets like you come with me you're
coming with me you're helping me fight
these demons that I'm trying to fight
right now and it's kind of superhero
genre and then it ends with all them
flipped into the world of the MCU and I
think it just has to be like small
little cameos and then later we can
explore these carrots whichever of the
characters my other four HS we really
like we can do this with Deadpool really
easily we just stopped by sister
Margaret's bar or something like that
and then you can drag in a version of
Deadpool with just like a quick cameo
and I think you need to kind of do this
with Charlie Cox because I don't know if
I want a season four of that version of
daredevil and I don't know if Disney
Plus once said either right like that's
a Netflix thing that's a direct
competitor with them they kind of want
to take the best of the character that
they can but but not the worlds that
existed in the Netflix thing and maybe
they can get some of the other
characteristic of Jones or or Luke Cage
they can they can pull some of the
things they liked about hopefully Frank
Castle Punisher because he was another
example someone who's perfect and then
just kind of reestablished them in the
world of the MCU and I would love to see
Charlie Cox truly defend a Hell's
Kitchen as it is today which is not like
the working-class community it was in
the 70s with a character rose up it's
like a super gentrified part of
Manhattan now and I want to see what new
problems Matt Murdock Charlie Cox
daredevil has to fight in this new
version of Hell's Kitchen as New Yorkers
actually know it to be that's great Eric
and I do love it it's a favorite hobby
horse of yours to make wand division
some kind of skeleton key into whatever
we want can happen because it's magic
and it's fun right yeah which I love
that I want I want more craziness in the
MCU I also love you kind of mentioned
this idea that I don't know if I've
heard people talk about about how like
agents of shield and the Netflix shows
are impacted by the MCU movies but it
doesn't go the other way around it's
like a one-way stream right of impact
kind of right and that kind of makes
sense and that kind of insulates the MCU
from having to worry about a hundred
hours of serialized television Eric as
always your your theories are fun and
they make my mind race so for that I
award you won Sparkle buck to Sparkle
bucks all three Sparkle bucks yes three
Sparkle bucks and they print out on my
end like actual sparkle buddy Sparkle
buck currency extremely a nice day you
could redeem those for a free set so
that subway they see your sparkle bugs
look a little bit better miner literally
just paint posted no
but that's alright I have a great
printer here I have a great Sparkle
printer that ink gets everywhere but I
love it yeah
the exchange rate but dazzles the
sparkle bug wonderful Mt how is
daredevil gonna show up in the MCU well
I'm glad you asked me Zach because
though Eric's theory amazing spectacular
spot-on that's why they pay you the big
bucks
it's the big Sparkle but um I think
honestly that daredevil is going to
cameo at least cameo in the new Hawkeye
Disney Plus if that ever happens there's
a lot going on there and I this is how I
think it's gonna happen let me take you
on a journey back to a little year that
we like to call 2012 the year that
everyone thought the world was going to
end but we all knows English miniature
[Laughter]
picture this you're a 13 year old boy
Angelica just use your imagination 13
year old boy walking down the street
it's a beautiful day you got 20/20
vision and things are beautiful you know
birds chirping in the sky
you know black ladies talking too loud
on the phone but it's okay because
they're checking in other kids it's a
beautiful day and then BOOM this
explosions Hellfire range from the sky
the Chitauri are invading New York and
it's just chaos everywhere people are
screaming and the street blows up
causing a truck full of chemicals to
spurn off to the side into the direction
of an old man crossing the street and so
since you are a 13 year old boy with
20/20 vision you're just like I need to
save this man and so you go and push the
man out of the way and unfortunately get
blinded by the chemicals because that's
what happens when a car and when a truck
crashes with filled with chemicals and
obviously I'm talking about Matt Murdock
daredevil and that is how Matt Murdock
gets his powers now
over the course of the next six years he
gets trained by stick who is you know
gets trained how to hone his senses and
learn how to punch people in the face
with zero zero vision because that's
what happens with your blood um and so
he's like oh man now I can punch people
in the face real good wonder what I'm
gonna do with this then boom the snap
half the heroes in the world are gone
especially spider-man who was fighting
for the people of New York and so Matt
Murdock is like all right well all these
heroes are gone and crime is ramping up
I have to step in and become a superhero
so he becomes daredevil now I say all
this to say this ma'am
the Hawkeye series it is rumored that we
will dive into the days of when mr.
Clint Barton was a certain Ronan fellow
and so I think I think this is I don't
think it's gonna happen
I think that one day Clint is going to
be chasing a target and daredevil is
going to be chasing that same target
possibly someone from the hand who knows
and they run into each other and Clint
being Clint he's a murdering this dude
kills indiscriminately
well daredevil is a good Catholic boy
and he's like hey killings not cool and
Clint's like I don't care my family's
dead I gotta kill everybody you get a
haircut that doesn't make any sense for
my they come to blows because they have
two different types of superhero wing
like we see in daredevil season two and
that fight happens and it probably
becomes a stalemate and probably I'm
guessing that Hawkeye probably figures
out that Matt Murdock is blind because
this dude has crazy good eyesight and
you can notice things a lot better than
a lot of other people can and so you
know freakin Daredevils catching his
arrows he's like what the heck is going
on and so it was like oh this kids
pretty impressive and they go their
separate ways and so one day while I'm
during the present day with Clint and
Kate Bishop they probably have to tackle
this super hard like challenge or enemy
and they're like oh man always we had
extra pair of hands
and then Clint's gonna be like hmm I
think I know a guy and then he looks
directly into the camera a daredevil
Hawkeye crossover episode where they
work together to fight crime so that's
what I think is going to happen know
what it's probably gonna happen
step by step we're just gonna admit that
you're psychic or something writing on
the show actually I love that theory you
also just really got me excited for like
2028 because that's probably when we're
getting our ha and so just to be clear
this is a full we're getting a new actor
everything's new about like not Charlie
Cox I love Charlie Cox but like that the
likelihood of Charlie Cox coming back at
daredevil is kind of low to me um unless
we're doing Eric's theory which is which
makes it a lot higher but yeah I think
it's gonna be a completely new daredevil
and I'm looking forward to you a new
interpretation me too
you sold me and for that I ordered you
one two three
sparkle buck yes go into your weights
printing out this printing Oh
it's been converted into this Funko pop
figure of James Gunn that uh actually
sent to me as a gift that is stuff
that's so cool
okay yeah and that was where Cleary
personal friend James Gunn yes that is
the three and I know that to be true
you're pinned tweet I believe is of you
and mr. gun yes right oh my god
literally greatest day of my life
meeting that man he's so cool and super
tall that dude is monstrously at all
like how tall like 6 feet tall like a
tree he's a nerdy tree yeah wonderful
Angelica how do you think we're gonna
get daredevil in the MCU okay um so just
kind of writing off of what MT just said
I I think that they're gonna introduce
him through she-hulk I don't know if
this one's too obvious but you know
lawyer' lawyer' I think it's gonna be
really easy to sort of slip daredevil in
to that world because the way I envision
it is the whole she-hulk series is going
to to happen and then maybe like a few
episodes in in the courtroom or in you
know the courthouse maybe like there'll
be a meeting and they'll cross paths or
something like that and she Hulk will
end up meeting our friend daredevil and
then I'm thinking like by some twists of
fate they're going to cross paths as
like heroes
so Daredevils already going to be
established I don't think we're gonna
see his origins but they're just sort of
going to to throw him into the world
through she-hulk
and through that courthouse and maybe
like there will be goons or something
that'll appear in the parking lot of the
courthouse a little too soon but they're
gonna throw them in there yeah I don't
know if that's like too obvious but
that's the way I see it I'm just really
excited for she-hulk and I love
daredevil and I really hope that they
keep Charlie Cox I really hope they do
if they end up listening to the actual
fan base of daredevil everybody loves
Charlie Cox so hopefully they you know
Marvel listens to that may they reflect
that you know so maybe like a
his walking stick and he just holds the
elevator door or something and yeah what
a great image just like I'm gonna do
them in the mill evader yeah those epic
moments where we like to see you know
maybe like a grand entrance but some of
my favorite entrances you know through
marble do you know Disney franchises
have been when you see the character and
you're like is that and then you find
out it is and you're just like oh like
you're surprised and you're delighted
and you just get a little taste of them
and then they come back in later I love
that see I really like that idea
considering that if you think about it
like Jennifer is this large green woman
and so like everybody in her day-to-day
is probably like oh my god like look at
this huge green woman but like since
he's blind he's just like hey you're a
normal person to me hello let's good
friends sure she'll probably like oh man
this is mom this is my boy he's just
curious we like an over person I like I
like that idea a lot yeah Nelson and
Murdock and Walters or Walters and
Nelson and Murdock yes gopher yes I yeah
I just imagined Matt Murdock trying to
like hit c4 to get like his Nutter
butters and it gets stuck and then this
Seahawk walks by and just waxing
literally like Nutter Brothers keeps me
Brown quick Nutter Butter break through
this video we've been angling for
another bunny I know it's the dream I
love that theory Angelica I love it so
much you get one sparkle buck worth of
Nutter butters to sparkle bucks for the
Nutter butters three Sparkle bucks worth
of Nutter butters oh my god
worth more than regular sparkle box I
think something happened in train
halation I don't know I got this sweet
Batman Pez oh okay yeah yeah very cool
wonderful great that was that given to
you by James Gunn here's a garage full
of toys
wonderful well it actually speaking of
James Gunn and directors that maybe have
been given the keys to more than one
franchise we're gonna talk about that in
a moment but first you want to give a
quick shout out to some of the people
that helped us bring rogue theory to you
specifically we've got some new friends
this week from shipstation if you're an
e-commerce seller right now is a wild
time and shipstation is here to help
when we at new rock stars have tried to
ship things in the past like new rock
stars merch or other things right it's
very confusing we're not shipping
experts and sometimes it's hard to tell
where something is on the shipping
pipeline you're not sure if you're being
charged the right amount for shipping
and shipstation helps online sellers of
any size get orders out quickly save
money on shipping costs and keep
customers happy they'll get you the
shipping rates normally reserved for
fortune 500 companies even if you're a
small outfit like new rock stars which
is awesome it's the fastest easiest and
most affordable way to manage and ship
your orders just a few clicks and you'll
be managing your orders printing out
labels and getting your product to happy
customers which is the best kind of
customer shipstation makes it easy they
work with all the major carriers like
UPS and FedEx and their interface brings
your products together whether you're
selling know an Etsy or Amazon or your
own website shipstation is the number
one choice of online sellers you'll ship
more in less time with the best rates
available and right now you can try
shipstation free for 60 days when you
use offer code rogue ro gue make sure
your business is ready to meet the
demands of delivery culture get started
at shipstation comm today click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in rogue or
gee you eat and that's obsession calm
then enter offer code row ship station
calm make ship happen okay
sometimes our online research for new
rock stars videos takes us into some
pretty questionable places Eric is the
author or co-author of several videos
that my poem of this category including
videos about the sexual history of both
Emperor Palpatine and the Incredible
Hulk
okay I am on several lists and it sounds
like that right um in incognito mode
right like even if it's not getting
saved in your history your ISP still
knows exactly what your google searching
for and so that's why we add new rock
stars and you too should be using
expressvpn expressvpn is an app that
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers so your ISP
can't see the sites you visit expressvpn
keeps all your information secure by
encrypting a hundred percent of your
data with the most powerful encryption
available it runs in the background
while you're serving the internet you
just tap one button and boom you're
protected and nobody can see where
you're going it's really easy and fast
expressvpn is available on all your
devices phones and computers even your
smart TV there's no excuse for you not
to be using it all the time so protect
your online activity today with the VPN
rated number one by CNN wired visit our
exclusive link expressvpn calm /r o ro
ug UE and you can get an extra three
months free on a one-year package that's
exp ar e SS VPN comm slash rogue
expressvpn con slash rogue to learn more
oh you know we put out this episode of
rogue theory every week I'm always happy
to be a part of usually behind the
scenes and also kind of behind the
scenes there's a discord rope theory
that goes on every week where we recruit
three awesome patrons who are on our new
rockstars discord server and each of
them submits their own rogue theory
based on the topic that we throw out
there and this week we threw out there
based on
last week's news about Henry Cavill
possibly playing Superman again we asked
our three awesome patrons like how is
that gonna happen
how was he showing up what property is
he gonna show up in and we got some
really good answers a sudden thunder and
AJ had great theories built around a
Superman solo movie or bizarro fighting
the Justice League were there two
respective answers but the winner this
week was Ruby he had this great idea for
Superman to show up in Shazam - yeah
kind of rectifying that very strange
torso only cameo Shazam movie and this
like totally blows it out Superman is a
huge part of the second movie as he kind
of like starts off battling against the
Marvel family but he's kind of being
controlled by mr. mind at a different
point it was like incredibly well
thought out answer Erik I know you
really like yeah I loved it it also tied
in black Adam Alisa mistaken and it gets
really dark like it finds a way to bring
in Black Adam Superman mr. mine and the
whole Marvel family all the kids
Shazam like it gets dark like they they
lock up all the prisoners to try to like
they have a contest like a social media
contest to try to lock up all the
prisoners Ruby really thought this out
really well but then like Black Adam
kills them all those prisoners just like
it would make this dark point like you
guys got to get on discord so you can
see all these theories and you guys vote
on them I think it's like I got to be
honest a lot of these theories that you
guys had discord have been putting out
there like it rivals if not best some of
the stuff we were able to come up with
on this show so it forces us to f our
game to be like all right you guys good
puts us out of this I could put some
more thought in the mind so well done
movie this is really a great theory I
also I particularly like the idea of
like Henry Cavill and the rock on the
same screen at the same time would there
be like any room for anybody else
there'll be so many muscles yeah all the
testosterone would leave my
yeah so check out that theory and
everything else that's going on on our
discord server where we're doing our MCU
rewatch alongs and there's trivia and
there's all kinds of really fun stuff
and you can join that discord server by
becoming a patron of new rock stars so
check that out okay our second topic
today and this is one that I really love
because I love rampant speculation about
directors and franchises and so uh with
obviously the Snyder cut kind of getting
its justice pun intended right and like
it that's gonna get released and in
twenties love it thank you thank you a
lot of directors and Quarantine have
been doing these like Twitter rewatch
alongs and things like that including
like David Ayer the director of the
first suicide Squad movie he's kind of
like hinted at there might be like his
own version of that movie and it's it's
allowed people kind of this free time to
re-examine a lot of different movies
including some the people didn't really
enjoy the first time around or might be
considered kind of a critical or a
commercial failure and might have even
put those directors into kind of
director jail which is an industry term
it's not a real place right that's when
you've kind of lost your privileges to
make a big-budget movie and maybe you
have to go DIRECTV or much smaller
budget movies or something like that
and so we just wanted to throw out there
who's the director for you there might
be a director jail right now he or she
might not be allowed to make one of
these big studio movies but you really
like what they've done in the past and
you think they actually could be really
successful with an existing or a future
property so Angelica why don't you start
us off so does anyone remember Dredd yes
okay I like okay so I'm thinking maybe
Pete Travis who directed Dredd I think
he did one of the better versions of
dread and he made a beautiful movie like
I think the cinematography was amazing
the violence was kind of stylized almost
and you know I'm always gonna root for
that sort of dystopian cyberpunk
director that's I just love that stuff
and like obviously he's really good at
casting because Lina Headley Karl Urban
like that I don't know that's pretty
amazing so I think he could maybe
repurpose or they could use him again as
a director for something maybe like I
don't know I think you'd be really good
for blade like something with a lot of
violence and I don't know I think it's
just a skill to be able to take Dredd is
such a one-dimensional kind of character
and still make a really beautiful movie
around it so yeah I think he could do a
lot with with Blade interesting yeah
that's a really I love that Angelika I
was a big fan of Dredd it kind of came
out at the peak of like 3d movies when
like everything was getting converted or
taking advantage of 3d and that movie
had some insane like it did some of the
best of all the 3d kind of spectacular
usamma really well shot yeah yeah it's
like Lena Headey is like a drug dealer
it has some kind of weird you know
powdery drug thing that makes people
move in slow-mo it wasn't visually an
incredible movie it if any if any of the
viewers haven't seen that go back and
watch drag yes I love that idea I love
both Pete Travis and blade those both
seem like far enough outside the box
things I love it Angelica you get one
sparkle buck and two sparkle bucks for
that theory got it mr. Leggett lovely
wonderful MT who's who are you releasing
from director jail well I shall release
Marc Webb from director jail for good
he doesn't cry as much I used to so I
really appreciate that no Marc Webb the
director of course of the amazing
spider-man movies I think that those
movies are underrated like I know that
like I'm not supposed to say that I
enjoy the mazing spider-man to you and
everybody's like oh my god it's the
worst spider-man movie though that may
be true oh like the actual stuff in
those movies weren't fantastic it just
had a bad script so like I'm chalking
yeah I'm shocking all of that negativity
about amazing spider-man 2 just bad
writing Marc Webb did the best that he
could with what he had and he made a
spectacular looking movie like I
constantly go back and look at the Times
Square fight from the amazing spider-man
2 and the final fight between spider-man
and electro and also via the final fight
between spider-man and Green Goblin it
just it just looks visually amazing
though it wasn't a messy movie it looks
really good and like the stuff that he
did in the first movie especially with
like and I mean spider-man 1 he had like
really cool camera angles like at one
point there was like a first-person view
of like Peter swinging across the city
and like the crane scene in Amazing
Spiderman waa fantastic like Marc Webb
knows how to make a really good looking
superhero film but also he hits hard
with the emotion like after Peter um
after Uncle Ben died in the first
amazing spider-man movie when Peter goes
back to school like that it's like a
really emotional scene I was actually
watching it right before the show and
like I was kind of getting choked up
because Andrew Garfield's performance
was spectacular no pun intended knows
how to capture like a really emotional
scene so I think that we give Marc Webb
another go at his universe I think that
we should have a Miles Morales
spider-man film set in the Amazing
Spiderman you
we kill off Andrew Garfield like Peter
Parker died in the comics and have Miles
Morales take over and become the
spider-man in that universe so when we
inevitably get that spider-verse film we
can have Tom Holland we can have Tobey
Maguire and then we can have this third
Miles Morales working together as like a
kind of like a celebration of Sony's
spider-man in general because I don't
think that Andrew Garfield and Sony are
on the greatest of times right now I
would love Andrew Garfield on my dealer
to be in a spider-verse movie but like I
don't I don't think that's gonna happen
so like I really think Marc Webb could
do it I honestly think you could do it
man you can really rock out that Miles
Morales spider-man film you honestly you
had me at Miles Morales just like let
Mars like let Marc Webb do a Miles
Morales movie I was already sold that
already sounds great and it also sounds
like that solves some of the problem of
amazing spider-man 2
there's just so much going into that
movie and they had to establish so many
characters with so many like disparate
plot lines but that is that seems like
that'd be a good use of his skill to
actually kind of narrow his focus back
down but then you added in this totally
insane spider-verse for killing Angie
Garfield but Tobey Maguire is still
alive okay sure
I'm along again you get to Sparkle by
God for that this is a crackling pop now
oh my birthday from my friend Murray
hello Murray if you're watching this so
we got the gun brothers together that's
right yeah nice they're hanging out so
wonderful okay Eric who's your director
that needs another shot okay we have a
director who I don't think she's in
director jail yet but she is going
through the justice system right now I
think she's that arraignment and they're
scheduled a in the first court trial day
they're their pick they're going through
Fuad ear for the jury Kathy Ann
birds-of-prey director right she I think
it has such a beautiful visual style the
way she uses come
the way that she can set the camera
inside the characters mind and wrap the
production design of the whole film as
an extension of the character's point of
view is brilliant and I think birds of
prey a flawed movie but definitely had
some cool things going on that I feel
like she should be given another shot I
don't know if Harley Quinn was the best
fit for for what Kathy Ann can do why
would I would love to see her do guys
have been watching them see movies
mantis is one of the coolest characters
to just watch in these movies every time
compliment if is in the background like
she is making crazy awesome choices and
she's an empath but we never see what's
going on inside her mind and I think
Kathy Ann could do such a good job for
like a mantis spin-off movie or a
miniseries or even just like a sequence
with another film of just showing the
world through mantises eyes of like just
like explosions of color and emotions
flooding her subconscious of as she's
like making contact with people or
trying to interpret things people are
telling her to do like I feel like Kathy
Ann could could open up mantises mind
and her her visions more than anyone
else I would love to see a mantis like
soullow something because like mantis in
the comics she's like a like a badass
when against combat she could kick a lot
of people's ass and like so I would love
to see here grow into that kind of like
you know kind of like combat combative
character well also like Eric said like
exploring that like internal emotion
part of mantis which is pretty pretty
dope Eric I love it and I've never
thought about a man to spin-off but now
that you've mentioned it I can't stop
thinking about it she definitely she's
one of my favorite characters in the MCU
I'm also intrigued she's one of my
favorite characters but we get such tiny
bites of mantis be very interesting to
see if she could carry a property but I
do I agree Kathy Yan would be a great
person to helm that so you also get to
Sparkle bucks as your Sparkle it's great
and they come out my end I think these
are mantis colors all right golden green
if let it be known everybody I've given
everyone the exact same amount of
sparkle bucks for all their theories
clearly that devalues the entire
principle of sparkle bucks and really
erodes the financial system of rogue
theory everything is meaningless but
that changes as we head into my favorite
section of the show Road questions okay
and a little peek behind the curtain
though I'm rarely on rogue theory I'm
often working on it behind the scenes
and I am the author of most of the road
questions okay so this is a segment of
this show you hate I am to blame and
it's definitely not a section of the
show you like because almost nobody
makes it this far in the episode okay so
but this week's road questions actor and
sometimes meme Ryan Gosling was
announced as he's playing The Wolfman in
an upcoming Universal horror Wolfman
movie and of course I'm a big fan of the
Ryan Gosling hey girl
memes so when will your Wolfman themed
hey girl
boyfriend meme say hey girl sweatpants
or dress you always look like a snack to
me all right let me let me try this
ah hey girl if your vagina was a
villager I would eat her first and I'm
alright I'll continue down this this
dark girl so you like Wolfman well
welcome to the Omega verse this alpha is
just gonna not with that Omega feel free
- why
don't look up the Omega nurse if you
aren't into Wolf kink community I might
have added myself as not being into
Wolfgang Chi did not get that reverence
somewhere so we're watching this episode
is like he does your community
we don't kinks in here and we will not
stop at this channel until we shine a
light on every different kink subculture
we see you throw knees we see you okay
this week as I see the 40th anniversary
of the Empire Strikes Back coming out
which that movie in addition to giving
us so much great things to build most of
our channel above also gave us Yoda it
was the debut of Yoda so how about this
is one of my favorite things to do let's
do some Yoda voice each give me in your
best Yoda what what our little green
friend what kind of advice would he give
us in the year 2020
I'll do the the feared leads to anger
thing but I feel like a 2020 Yoda would
have a couple more links to that
equation so here leads to anger anger
leads to hate hate leads to suffering
suffering leads to apathy apathy lead to
boredom boredom leads to do random
online toxicity online toxicity leads to
the comments section of our Rick and
Morty breakdowns because all of your
trash tell us how you really feel
okay I have a good one I have a good one
right okay okay
why am I like this all right so you know
the classic do or do not all right poor
Pune there is no ply all right my turn
I'll keep it simple hmm wake up in the
morning you should not 2020 is a
disaster actually all three of you
exceeded expectations on the Yoda
impression you all committed very well
nobody just talked backwards and claimed
that that was a good impression good on
all of you you you respected our little
green buddy and that concludes this
episode of rogue theory now again I've
been totally equivalent it's been a real
socialist episode where everybody gets
to see Ramona so there's no winners we
all we all win well I do want to say
this yes we're all winners thank you all
you've all been wonderful guests because
he's a first-time guest I feel like um
if there has to be kind of a designated
winner it should be our new buddy empty
Wow why does there else empty did you
have a wish you would like enacted as
our designated winner um yes I do um
it's a bit of a weird wish but I would
like each of you in your most seductive
way possible to save the phrase I love
master tainment
in the most seductive way possible
hey girl and ask me southern I was doing
it McConaughey a little bit there cuz
nothing okay I think there's there's
there's saxophones just imagine there
everywhere so many saxophones they're
playing over each other the plane like
Careless Whisper or something and it's
like dude you do hey wait I'm saying hey
girl again why did you do this me right
it's just I love master tainment yes and
there okay I'm I'm almost said Nic Cage
like this same difference honestly I
don't know I'm mixing them up alright
doo-doo-doo saxophones playing oh I love
master tainment any any time I need to
channel seductive I just think about my
feelings towards chicken wings okay Wow
I feel that a Steve EULA I love Master
tiin well deserved thank you so much for
being on the show everyone
Angelica Trey Trey on on Twitter and
other social media platforms what would
you like to folks to know a tray I like
you guys to know Tobey Maguire's best
friend right now um so I haven't to look
at tray thank you guys for having me
back on today I appreciate everybody so
so much you can find me on those social
medias at a tray a YY t ra e as well as
on twitter under there and my instagram
angelica tray thank you guys
wonderful empty thank you so much and
congratulations on winning this episode
we're working folks find you uh you guys
can find me on YouTube and Twitter and
Instagram and my home at master tainment
that is like entertainment but master
tainment
I post a lot of weird [ __ ] I have a
guardians of the galaxy Easter egg hunt
maybe if you guys want to join me in I'd
welcome you like just come on in we'll
find this thing together and I just post
like um like just weird comic book
videos where I explain concepts in a
like I think a funny way in a weird way
I'm just a weirdo so we'll come on down
so youtube.com slash master tainment yes
I understand I'm a fan of your videos as
well and and Eric folks can find you at
EA vas yeah I'm the socials oh that's
right Instagram Twitter hey boss you can
find me just click on one of the videos
on your sidebar hopefully it's the black
panther what cuz we've loved that very
so I love that movie so much do they
want baby people watch it and and yeah
another shout out to both Angelica and
empty both of them make amazing content
on other quarters of the internet and
this are James Gunn Easter egg hunt that
that we jumped on too way too late empty
really got that ball rolling so all
credit to that because you found stuff
that like blew my mind that I was like
holy [ __ ] this guy's on to something I
just have new life dude hey thank you
all we all have to go now - not live
lives I guess uh you will not find me on
the Internet in fact you'll never see me
again
[Music]